Hi, Vogue!
It's Hailey Bieber.
Today, I'm going to be showing you guys what I wear in a week.
To start, I wouldn't be in hotel slippers, so I'm going to take these Nike SBs,...
...fold those up like that because I just think it looks cooler.
And then I'm going to put it with this cool like charcoal gray coat...
...that is from Lemaire.
I love a really long sleeve on a coat.
It's everything to me.
I love this sweatshirt because it's like a little bit worn and it's vented,...
...but it is that yummy fleece on the inside.
I love these Margiela pants.
I've had them for a long time.
I love the way that they fit.
This is a very cozy cashmere Bottega Veneta sweater.
I feel like I'm gonna be able to have this sweater for twenty years...
...and it's never gonna go out of style and my kids can steal it from me one day.
So, this is my casual Saturday look,...
...and I am wearing these really cool baggy Natasha Zinko jeans that I love.
They're a little bit more tomboy.
I've been photographed in these jeans quite a few times.
They're my favorite fit.
I love these ones.
I don't care to repeat them.
This sweater is from Mango.
It's so easy to just throw on.
It's a great color.